en gros pour voler bon il ya plusieurs
manières de rentrée pour le véhicule
peut déboîté le carreau puis écarté la
porte c'est un petit boîtier que tu
viens branchés comme l'ordinateur que ce
soit le boîtier ou l'ordinateur tu veux
le brancher à ces deux prisons choisi la
voiture ouais je choisis le véhicule
je vais pas vous montrer comment on fait
quelle est la procédure assure mais en
tout cas c'est avec ce logiciel là qu'on
peut ce genre de logiciel et ce genre
d'outils qu'on peut pirater le véhicule
au monde en quelques secondes pendant 20
ans voila j'aimerais des voitures dans
des endroits comme dégage comme ce
garage là par exemple j'ai toujours eu
une idée précise de ce que de ce que des
modèles que je visais ont choisi par un
modèle par hasard on choisit un modèle
qui va se revendre à coup sûr facilement
qui est plutôt passe partout pour éviter
de se faire repérer c'est pas un plaisir
de voler des véhicules à des gens et de
et et d'imaginer la personne qui va se
retrouver le lendemain sans sa voiture
alors qu'elle va au travail emmener ses
enfants à l'école mais en tout cas où
elle le il ya un côté risque et toutes
façons de la chose donc ça déclenche
forcément quelque chose une montée
d'adrénaline
et interne c'est ce qu'on va chercher
quoi presque du coup les voitures je les
revendais sur des plateformes de vente
entre particuliers de véhicules
d'occasion entre particuliers et je
donnais souvent d'un rendez-vous dans
des des vieux comme celui-là parking du
cinéma et un jour le client c'est un ver
est un policier
et donc c'est lui que j'étais censé
vendre la voiture et mais au final
c'était un piège et dont je sais comme
ça que nous se fait attraper presque
soulagé ouais parce que parce que je ne
serai pas arrêter ses ventes en fait tu
as quand même une vie de famille et à
des enfants voilà le résultat c'est
qu'ils viennent au parloir
c'est pas top comme perspective d'avenir
pour les enfants de les enfants de 8 et
3 ans
[Musique]
il
une
j'ai eu une peine de trois ans dont deux
ferme et évidemment cela laisse le temps
de réfléchir
bien sûr donc au bout d'un an au bout
d'un an je me suis j'ai eu voilà comment
un déclic je me suis dit pas assez d'eux
venu comme une évidence de de profiter
des compétences que j'avais acquis
pendant toute cette période là toute
cette connaissance et de la mettre au
service de la sécurité pour protéger les
automobiles et pour inventer un antivol
penser avec un nouveau regard nouveau
genre dans six voix le connecter et qui
pourrait m'empêcher de voler des moyens
j'étais dans une association d'insertion
et du coup bah c'est aussi une insulte
je rencontre d'autres détenus et essai
de de t'en sortir de travail et de
clochers aussi et il y avait un bénévole
avant qu'ils aient hugo qui m'a dit dira
station qui va proposer bientôt un
programme pour les gens issus de la
diversité et il m'a dit j'ai coché
toutes les cases vas-y après avoir
entendu mon projet les toits du coup je
suis arrivé ici à la station f
après sélection de dossiers donc parler
press start up par 1800 d'aussi j'ai été
élu par même 1000 start up
dans les quarante les plus prometteuses
de la station répond donc ça me permet
de rester un peu plus longtemps de
pouvoir mature et mon projet de pouvoir
gagner en visibilité
bah ouais c'est je me suis créé ma
propre activité
je me jeu je me suis je me suis élevé
socialement tout seul entre guillemets
tout seul bien sûr mais mais ce que je
veux dire c'est pas attendu après un
patron etc
donc voilà il faut c'est important si on
a un projet d'aller au bouton au bout de
son projet vraiment c'est ignorer qu'on
pense
donc ouais clairement ma vie a changé g
j'ai trois employés je peux prendre ma
fille en stage lui apprendre comment
monter sa boîte
ces jeux commença à la faire rentrer
dans un réseau taux auquel n'aura pas eu
accès si j'avais continué mes conneries
la maman un peu commencé à penser
apprendre à côtoyer les gens qui vont la
faire
ces levées ou qui ont lu facilité en
fait qui vont ouvrir des portes d'autres
portes du monde de l'entrepreneuriat
voilà le rêve de monter soit centre
équestre sera plus facile avec les clés
que j'ai voulu donner
[Musique]